i like to have my speaker to put like a
kind of like a good mood
i mean even in in your bedroom it's
important to have a speaker
hey eq is your boy alejandro and this is
my 10
essentials
so yeah my first item is hooties
i'm not low-key guys i always put my
hood on
you know running away from the paparazzi
no i'm just kidding no i just like this
style and i don't know i like black
hoodies
black is one of my favorite colors
because you can combine it with every
everything you know right now i'm
wearing uh affinity it's one of my
brother's hoodies
i'm from my island so it's really hot
there
so when i go to the studios and they got
the
air conditioning or if i travel and it's
cold
i get cold real quick because you know i
don't know
i like the hot weather i'm from the hot
weather i'm not from the cold
this is like a package you know phone
and my charger
yeah i'm always in my phone i cannot
live with my phone it's not
it's not because i'm addicted to it it's
just you know i'm always like
like hustling you know like doing my
move and always thinking what i'm gonna
do next
my notes are here so i always use my
notes for like
ideas that i have on my mind uh lyrics
uh schedule calendar you know you got
everything here
it's really important you know i always
like to be in contact with my family
this is really important and my charger
i started worrying when it's five
percent at five percent i'm like
screaming like
yo where's my charger
charger that charged really quick but i
use my phone
most of the time just for creating stuff
you know i'm always creating
new ideas half of my brain is here
yeah i'm telling you snapple
yo this is the best juice in america
strawberry kiwi is my favorite flavor
yeah most of the time i drink this
i mean even like before the interview i
started drinking it
and they said yo this is for the
interview i was like damn i need to save
it so
after this this is done
so i always have this juice every day
my friends my family everyone knows what
is my favorite juice so they always buy
it to me
i use it for the breakfast i use it for
lunch for dinner
when i'm in the studio too before
show uh during the playing everything i
got my snap hole
you know i train a lot so i deserve it
this is heaven
alright so my next item is perfume
i love this brand lafayette street bomb
from paris
this is special this one is i have it
always in my
in my backpack though the fragrance is
so nice
and elegant and i always like to be
you know smelling good i'm a ladies man
you know
for the girls important perfect
i gotta become important are you
smelling good but you need to have your
good flavor in your mouth you never know
when you gonna find like a
date i mean i like a lot of flavors it
doesn't matter the brand
it's just mint um and you know candy
bubble gum stuff like that i like
cinnamon too i mean it's not my favorite
one
i mean gum always important to have it
in my
back body lotion yeah i got a lot of
tattoos
i don't know around my body and i always
like to
put cream on it to you know to make it
more like um
shiny yeah i got like ah
feel sick i don't know what to say in
english you gotta know so like a
dry dry skin dry skin i use louis
vuitton
this is a good brand he got no fragrance
so it's kind of like
healthy how many tattoos i have i think
i lost count
more on the way yeah for sure
alright so next item speakers
beats this is really cool to have
whatever you put it like
it's good i don't like the silence well
when i go when i'm going to sleep yet of
course but
i do in my day whenever i would stop
we stop in a friend's house a green room
you know waiting for a meeting
or wherever working with producers
they send me beats i mean i like to hear
it in my headphones too but
i like to hear like out loud i can feel
the body better
yo my next item is really important to
me
el rosario i came from a catholic
family you know i'm christian i think
god is
the most important thing in life i've
been raised
with that and you know i got fake so
this reminds my my family my mother
she was the one who taught me about
rosario
also my grandmother they teach me how to
pray when i was little
and most of the time i pray you know
during the night during the day
so i always have it on me i don't have
it on me most of the time
i just have it on my back and when i you
know got that space to
to pray a little bit just take it out
and
yeah rosario
yo stay here after the camera say hi to
the ladies he's a sexy guy he's a sexy
guy
yeah this is my this is not a item this
this is my
my boy i need to have this guy on my
side every day
he fly with me to everywhere yo stay
here to the camera say hi to the ladies
leaving miami so like short flight like
two hour flight three hour flight he
goes with me
he's in my car every day um we have a
lot of fun
he always like missing all my stuff
yeah but i love him a lot so it gives me
like
concentration you know like you feel
like some someone is waiting for you at
home
and that feeling is is kind of nice you
know to have that feeling
and taro taro is my you know i don't
have a baby so
yeah this is like my baby it's still a
um it's on training it's intense
a lot of energy my next
essential is my brother francis yo come
on francis say hi to the gq family
so i got francis here i'm with these
guys since i was a kid
and 19 uh essential part of artists
is just a teamwork you know i cannot
live with this guy like i just woke up
and i
was first person that talk is winning
like scared careful calling their
everything and
we start from the bottom now we're here
it's like it's about half of my brain
i'm telling you
i'm telling you it's a it's not real
essential in my life
and i think there's no one better than
him to do
what we do you know me better than
anyone and
you know thanks to him and my team i'm
i'm here you know
and i'm really grateful the mustache she
got the best mustache in the world
i didn't wax it today but
it's okay yeah you can go now all right
all right eq thanks for checking it out
she bought it out
goodbye
all right we could wiggle